all right Donald Trump served me in the
polls the left there starting to panic
the liberal group citizens for
responsible and ethics responsibility
and ethics followed the lawsuit today in
a desperate attempt to block Trump from
appearing on the primary ballot in
Colorado claiming of course they
supported the Insurrection he hasn't
even been charged with that and
therefore should be constitutionally
barred from running for office okay here
to react to that and by the way I
finally got my copy of the brand new
book I call him the great one Mark Levin
the Democratic party hates America
we will have the first interview with
Mark on radio and TV I'm looking forward
to it he also hosts the successful
top-rated show on the weekend life
liberty Levin great one how are me thank
me how are you I am great and great
wonderful audience there let me Jump
Right In first of all Sean on this
indictment the ruse is obvious I think
you're close to it which is indict him
on the gun charge he may actually get
off with this diversion but get off or
not it's the one charge they can bring
that if they have a trial they won't
bring in Papa Bear
if he's indicted on a tax issue if he's
indicted on pharah he could bring Biden
as a co-conspirator he can bring him in
in other ways you can open up an entire
line of questioning involving Joe Biden
on the gun matter is very narrow it's
very compartmentalized so it does not
affect Joe Biden directly so that's the
ruse that's taking place here that's
number one now on this 14th Amendment
you have to be the dumbest on the
face of the Earth to be proposing this I
you know you got two knucklehead
professors
who took 125 pages to tell us that
something's in this section that's not
in the section
you got a washed up federal judge here
with h Trump going on TV doing the same
thing you've got these these Democrats
who I thought hated the Constitution
because it was written by white
supremacists and so forth and so on but
then they cite the Constitution let's
dig into this Section 3 the 14th
Amendment anybody who can find the word
president other than president-electers
I will give you a thousand dollars no
I'll give you ten thousand dollars it's
not in there they mentioned Senators
congressmen Governors State legislators
state judges civilians military
personnel president vice president
electors but somehow the most powerful
person in the country is left out of
that list well he must have been
included in this phrase and an officer
of the United States now what they meant
by an officer of the United States was
some County Commissioner in South
Carolina they didn't mean the president
of the United States now do you think a
congress after the Civil War believed in
states rights where they actually
thought one state or a handful of States
whether they're legislatures or a
secretary of state or an attorney
general in that state would have the
power to deny a presidential candidate a
ballot position can you imagine when
they were attacking these states we
still had military occupation in several
of these states that they would give
that kind of authority they never gave
that kind of authority how do we know
because there's nothing that says they
did so we have these phony originalists
who are now activists we have these
activists who are always phony activists
who saying that that's what was meant
now what do we mean by Insurrection or
sedition
well we know what they meant when they
passed the 14th Amendment and ratified
it in 1868. you know what they meant
Sean the Civil War that's what they
meant anyone who engaged in participated
in gay Aid and comfort to the Civil War
they were the ones who were banned from
holding public office they didn't mean
for this to apply after the last
Confederate died there's no evidence
that they did and of course they didn't
so what do we mean today by Insurrection
or sedition it doesn't matter Donald
Trump's not been charged by for
Insurrection or sedition and you know
why he's not been charged America
because two days before January 6 when
this so-called Insurrection took place
he offered ten thousand
military personnel to defend the Capitol
building and defend the members of
Congress on January 6th he was turned
down by the Democrat speaker in the
Democrat mayor can you imagine bringing
that charge against Trump I would love
that case I go in court and I'd say to
the jury let me get this straight he's
the only one who offered ten thousand
men armed in military equipment and gear
to surround that building to protect
them on January 6th he was turned down
by the Democrats well that's a hell of a
way to run an Insurrection don't you
think let's see so he authorized the
proud boys and The Oath Keepers to have
an Insurrection they have no evidence of
that they have no evidence of anything
because it doesn't make any sense that's
one of the reasons now
there's a way to remove a president you
impeach him you have to convict him in
the Senate they tried this the second
impeachment was about January 6th and
they impeached them they impeached him
without a hearing they impeached him
without due process they impeached him
without him providing any evidence it
was a perfect stalinous trial except it
was even faster than Stalin Stalin at
least gave him 48 hours and 72 hours
before they popped the top of the head
off the guy here they did it right away
then they held a rump trial in the
Senate and they didn't come close to the
super majority votes they needed to
convict Donald Trump so if anything
under our constitutional system Donald
Trump was adjudicated not guilty of an
Insurrection in a sedition by the one
body that took it up the United States
Senate under our constitutional system
it is Scoundrels it is saboteurs dressed
up as tenured law professors as former
federal judges these radical left-wing
Democrat groups they're bringing these
lawsuits you'll know why they want to
disenfranchise 70 75 million Americans
mostly Republicans they don't believe in
the Constitution they don't believe in
the voting system they want to destroy
the Electoral College we're on to them
now the question is that the Judiciary
has any Integrity left and Integrity
left will they not only turn this down
but will they hold any lawyer who brings
this kind of case into court will they
sanction them or send them to the bar to
be disbarred that's it I'm done
that's why we call them the great ones
Democratic party hates America out we'll
have the first interview with Mark Mark
thank you life liberty Levin Sunday
nights 8 PM hope you'll join him don't
miss it hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else